but sufi's I often say they tend to
emphasize certain things more perhaps
than the non-non Sufi Muslims so to say
and love is one of those things
uh one of the most famous early sufises
of Basra a female Sufi who lived in the
late
um 8th early 9th century and she is
often seen as one of the earliest
people who who talks about this concept
of love as a central theme and in
particular as a sort of like I said a
form of worship that it's not just that
we are Servants of God which we are also
we are the the
and we are in Arabic it's called Abed so
our Servants of God
but we are also
in a loving relationship with God we
love God and love God loves us and so
there is that relationship which is at
the core of Islamic worship